hey guys I'm Ryan right hi there I'm
Veronica success and I'm Randy price
we're gonna watch the red band trailer
today for unfinished business a dave
Franco brother of Jamie Franco Vince
Vaughn brother of John Favreau is that
interesting
Thanks I do want to establish that I'm
not in the middle today I wanted to
prove my love by telling my girlfriend
no you sit next to the lady okay like
it's green
you guys came together today that's
Oh
Louie CK had a bit similar to that it
was kind of cool to see like a scripted
take on that and being on the plane yeah
that looks fun I mean we've needed Vince
Vaughn to be in a movie like this for a
long time like since wedding crashers
he's not the same character but you know
it's more along the lines of the Vince
Vaughn that we really did like you know
what I mean chassé no I mean he did the
movie the alien movie and he was still
that same kind of the alien movie there
the oh yeah uh-huh yeah no one liked it
well I notice him like I was watching
dodgeball in dodgeball he is a little
bit more just a nice dude and wedding
crashers that's one like everything
everyone just lost their [ __ ] for his
bond that's Jim because he was just that
fast-talking guy and then in this one
what's cool about him is there seems to
be like an insecurity about him as
opposed to someone who is 100% confident
familiar yet different side of Vince box
well he's probably evolved too as you
know not only a person but I'm an actor
to bring that a little bit of depth that
third dimension oh yeah to his like
brashness dave Franco all right he's so
cute and hilarious his grin is like so
infectious yeah
is quince mm-hmm he's a doorman he's
really funny yeah he's cute
I am so okay with all those comments
because I have such security about my
spinner yeah I have composure Brandi I
cope with all the dick jokes jokes I
just you know I'm okay I just don't
think you were making a joke it didn't
sound like a joke well you don't think
he's cute adorable - of course I think
he's - you're adorable but I'm gonna say
that out loud to you Jesus James Martin
I love James Martin in every role except
Cyclops are so pretty but James Martin
is like the [ __ ] I think he's always so
fun and always so damn charming he was
psycho so he's kind of a boring Cyclops
but I really blame that more on the
script rather than the performance but
anyway that's beside the point well
let's take that for another episode I
like the rhythm of the back-and-forth
with everyone it has a cool style
yeah the pacing seems cool and just the
way the scenes play out like the
dialogue it's like you know some
comedies you're like this whole thing so
I can improvise but then you watch this
and it feels like they got a good script
really with good jokes actually backing
it up that's what is making me appealed
to this movie are these facts okay
because I'm smart smarter than all you
guys that's what makes me better and
that's why you watch because I am the
smartest one you know oh thanks dick
jokes if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects where
you know I say something funny after
this line but I want to be sincere today
and say that there is so much [ __ ] it's
like going on Netflix oh you don't know
what to watch they might turn away from
the channel I'm sorry but still
subscribed it looks good on paper Brandi
has a channel to the Brandi price
Channel Randy price actor or something
like that where she has videos and
Veronica has a channel where she does
vlogging and music covers and you know
we got something works in the pipeline
so yeah this is me sir
Dominator Burbank dumb and alter dumb
and alter jaemin alter can I get a
shout-out if I do I'll save a cat guns
blazing for I want to see if he doesn't
save the cat guns blazing 14 Happy
Thanksgiving video was hilarious and
you're a good person bro I am a boy with
brain cancer oh my god this got really
serious and I really enjoy your videos
if you could please give me a shout out
hate to someone get dick if that's true
that I'm a total dick for saying this
but no is like his massive sayin you
know be but if this is a joke
you got me what are you what if he's not
because there's plenty of people who
have said that kind of who said stuff to
me and I'm like I get really heartfelt
you know like woman who pretended she
had cancer so you can now understand no
I think that he probably does he needs a
nice shoutout from you baby give him a
nice shoutout
okay you know what's blazing a 14 year
olds guns is he 14 he says guns blazing
14 I could stand for me year true he
said he's a boy he also said that you're
a good person thing he has to realize is
I'm not a good person you know what your
shoutout was us trying to figure out how
we should give you a shout-out we love
you man and if you're being sincere then
yes we will say prayers for you there's
any way we can help you let us know
please I love goes out to you definitely
so transitioning I feel bad day manator
Burbank you can get a shout out I don't
want the cat to die thank so please save
that cat for us video post a video of
you saving the cat but then what if he
puts the cat in danger in the first
place just so that he could show in the
video that he's saving a cat what if
it's all fake though like he creates
like this fake town and this thing like
he's gonna be Godzilla or something and
then he's like it'd be funny if like he
was swinging the cat around its tail
then I run into a fire pit everything
like when and it got it that'd be fine
if it were everywhere paper cat and he
got the real cat I'm talking about like
a live reading Karen's or a kidding get
it would be funnier no I really hope you
don't think my buddies Marquis Rogers I
did a song for my girlfriend Veronica
she couldn't be here right now peace
said awesome job brother on my song
shout out to me
yeah I think he wants a shout out from
you Veronica oh no I think he's shouting
me out he's the thing hey what's up girl
you're all I caught on to that so I'm
saying you take the lead on responding
back Marquis Rogers your kick-ass guy
thank you so much for the shout out I
really liked it and I feel very special
now thank
you're the [ __ ] yeah that was good but
it couldn't use like a dick or [ __ ]
joke
well you did say awesome job